so
animals developed senses they developed
a head
like a literal head so amphioxus doesn't
even have a head really it's just
what's the purpose of a head that's a
great question
is it is it to have a jaw that's a great
question
so jaw so yes jaws are a major
um useful feature yeah obviously they're
a major adaptation
after there's a split between
vertebrates and invertebrates so
amphioxus is thought to be very very
similar to the animal that's
before that split but then after the
development
very quickly after the development of a
head is the development of a jaw
which is a big thing and um
and what goes along with that is the
development of a brain
it's weird is that just a coincidence
that the thing
the part of our body of the mammal i
think
body that we eat with and like
attack others with is also the thing
that contains
the uh all the majority of
the brain type well actually the brain
goes with the development of a head
and the development of of a visual
system and an auditory system
and an olfactory system and so on
you